and you look at how much the culture has
like like been degraded and it's not a
coincidence that like as the state
expands your culture gets more destroyed
if you look at it through every inch of
it right like through even the creation
of say like Social Security it's like
okay well without Social Security what
used to be the retirement plan well the
retirement plan used to be your kids
would take care of you so you're just
like incentivizing people to take really
good care of their kids so that their
kids then want to take care of them
before the rise of the welfare state
what was the welfare state it was your
local community it was your local church
it's like there's all of these
incentives to kind of like we build
communities for a reason because there's
natural incentives for us to all work
together and kind of like be
interdependent and then the state comes
in at every turn it like undermines like
all of those cultural norms and and like
incentivizes you to be dependent on the
state and it's horrible